Expresa en la forma de un monomio,
monomio al área de un rectángulo que mide 4xy de largo y 2y de ancho.
¿Ok? Monomio. Monomio lo que significa es que es un solo término, puede tener muchas cosas
multiplicándose, por ejemplo "x" cuadrada por "y" a la 5 por 12
pero el chiste es que no se le sume a ninguna otra cosa.
¿Ok? Tenemos el área de un rectángulo que mide 4xy de largo.
A ver dibujemos nuestro
rectángulo y de largo mide
4xy y de ancho mide 2y entonces, queremos sacar el área
pero, el área, el área
de un rectángulo siempre es base por altura, o sea tomamos las longitudes de los lados
y las multiplicamos entonces, aquí nos queda que el área es igual a 2y por 4xy
¿Ok? Entonces ya nada más tenemos que simplificar esta expresión.
Aquí tenemos 2 por 4 por ejemplo que es igual a 8.
Siempre siempre que estamos multiplicando 2 expresiones de este tipo,
podemos reacomodar los términos ¿Ok? Siempre que todas estas cosas estén multiplicando,
si hay un más por allí en medio, ya no las podemos
reacomodar pero, éste está multiplicándose con éste,
con éste y con este entonces, los podemos reordenar y nos queda 2 por 4 que es 8,
después por aquí tenemos una "x" solita
y por aquí este "y" podemos pensar que es "y" elevado a la potencia 1 y este otro "y"
también podemos pensar que es "y" a la 1 y a la hora de multiplicarnos
podemos simplemente decir ¡Ah! "Y" por "y" tiene que ser y cuadrada
o podemos ver que tenemos la misma base que es "y"
elevado a distintas potencias y entonces nada más sumamos las potencias, y entonces nos queda la base
elevado a 1 más 1, 2
¿Ok? Entonces el área
área del rectángulo es igual a 8xy cuadrada y este sí es un monomio.